qué número tiene el mayor valor absoluto
esto de valor absoluto valor absoluto
simplemente es la distancia de un número
hacia el cero o sea qué tan grande es el
número sin importar su signo por ejemplo
la distancia de menos 17 a 0 es 17
porque menos 17 está a 17 unidades de
cero a la izquierda' entonces tenemos
que el valor absoluto de menos 17 de
menos 17 es igual a 17 a 17 de manera
similar el valor absoluto de menos 13 es
13 el valor absoluto de menos 13 es
igual a 13 porque el menos 13 está a 17
unidades a la izquierda del 0 el valor
absoluto de 15 de 15 es igual a 15
porque ahora está a 15 unidades a la
derecha pero otras veces nada más una
distancia así que aquí ya se puede ver
un patrón verdad simplemente el valor
absoluto de un número es considerar ese
número pero quitándole el signo si el
número es negativo se vuelve positivo y
si el número es positivo se queda
positivo siempre es un número
porque siempre estamos midiendo una
distancia a la distancia de ese número a
cero bueno el valor absoluto de 15 es 15
y el valor absoluto de 19
es igual a 19 y de entre estos números
estos 4 que encontramos tenemos que ver
cuál es el mayor que sería el 19
entonces la respuesta sería de y en este
caso coincide también con el número más
grande vamos ahora al problema número 2
en el problema número 2 nos preguntan
entre que dos enteros se encuentra el
valor de raíz de 61 raíz de 61 es un
número que seguramente tiene algunos
dígitos en su parte decimal no sé cuál
es entonces lo que nos están preguntando
aquí es básicamente si ignoramos eso que
el número queda a la izquierda y luego
tenemos que poner el siguiente entero va
bueno la forma de pensar esto es la
siguiente vamos a elevar estos números
al cuadrado los enteros al cuadrado y
queremos ver cuando esos enteros al
cuadrado queda uno por debajo de 61 y el
siguiente por arriba tantito por arriba
y tantito por abajo entonces vamos a ver
por ejemplo el 6 cuando lo elevamos al
cuadrado nos queda 36
36 y el 7 cuando lo elevamos al cuadrado
nos queda 49 49 y 61 no que hay entre
estos dos entonces raíz de 61 no puede
caer entre 6 y 7
mira podemos pensarlo así 6 es lo mismo
que raíz de 36 nada más eleve al
cuadrado y estoy sacando raíz y 7 lo
mismo que raíz de 49 entonces para que
raíz de 61 caiga entre 6 y 7 61 tiene
que caer entre 36 y 49 pero no sucede
entonces esta no es la respuesta vamos
vamos aquí con 7 y 8 tendremos que poner
raíz de 49 eso de allí 7 y de este lado
tenemos que poner raíz de 8 al cuadrado
es 64 raíz de 64 y entonces ahora si
claramente raíz de 61 que hay entre raíz
de 49 y raíz de 64 porque 61 está entre
49 y 64 y por lo tanto raíz de 61 está
entre 7 y 8 la respuesta sería b
vamos ahora al problema 3 de problema 3
dice usa las siguientes sumas para
responder la pregunta y aquí nos pone en
una tabla con algunas sumas un medio más
un cuarto es igual a tres cuartos
etcétera
entonces vamos a tener que utilizar esto
luego dice basado en este patrón cuál es
el valor de la suma un medio más un
cuarto más un octavo más un dieciseisavo
y seguimos sumando que son potencias de
un medio potencias de un medio hasta
llegar a 1 entre 1024 bueno pues vamos a
ver vamos aquí arriba a ver qué sucede
dice un medio más un cuarto es igual a
tres cuartos bueno creo que aquí todavía
no se ve el patrón un medio más un
cuarto más un octavo es igual a siete
octavos creo que aquí ya empiezo a ver
algo mira el denominador el denominador
del resultado es igual al denominador
del último término luego si cambiamos
acá el denominador también es igual a
este denominador y luego el número que
está en el numerador es uno menos o sea
si vamos de aquí para acá es de 8 a 7
restar 1 vamos a ver si así eso siempre
se cumple
vamos a agregar otro término más 1 entre
16 aquí está el 16 y aquí vuelve a
aparecer y el de arriba es 1 - entonces
justo ese es el patrón sale acá abajo
sería un medio más un cuarto más un
octavo más 1 entre 16 más 1 entre 32 en
el denominador nos queda el 32 y en el
denominador nos queda 1 - que sería 31
entonces ahí está el patrón conforme
vamos agregando términos el denominador
cambia a ser el denominador de la última
fracción y el numerador se vuelve uno
menos que ese denominador bueno entonces
aquí sería un medio o más un cuarto más
un octavo más un dieciseisavo hasta 1
entre 1024 entonces tendríamos que poner
el mismo denominador 1024 y en el
numerador 1 - que sería 1000 mil 23
vamos a ver si está en las opciones si
aquí esta sería la opción c 1.023 entre